you were the one Chris who is like
yesterday like this is the guy we should
get on I'm like how the hell did I not
think of that hey I knew it I mean this
is the man he is the man you could want
to listen to mad dog sports radio on the
mad dog sports radio channel on Sirius
XM you can hear and watch him every day
on high heat on MLB Network as well and
on his show his famed Super Bowl contest
where you can win a trip down to the
Super Bowl get a chance to get a pair of
tickets to Super Bowl 54 on his show he
is none other than Chris Mad Dog brew so
how are you Christopher
my main man I am doing fine I am doing
fine what do you think of the trash cans
stuff for the buzzing stuff and all this
stuff
what a joke I mean I'd say right now how
come the Astros haven't said a word in
the last 5-6 days all Bregman does is
hang out at Craigs in Hollywood a
knockin Nathan Ivaldi two years ago he's
got a lot to say about Verlander kicking
media guys out of the clubhouse because
it doesn't like Anthony fanuc of the
Detroit Free Press you know but that
story in the summertime you know Altuve
Correa stringer mr. Connecticut and of
course ger al you know old she did their
rear ends off and I haven't heard a word
out of them
you know they're an arrogant SWAT you
know cocky team and not a peep in the
last four or five days good job by
Manford I have no problem not naming the
players like it's actually better
because now we can the whole team gets
branded with this obviously Klain how to
do it he did the Mets finally they had
no choice to coach and how brought
Yvonne wagon in spent eight hours with
them before November first not asking
them about the whole thing with the
Astros we all knew that this is a
possibility is mind-boggling to me you
know it's an ugly story I don't I the
one thing I would say to be fair I don't
want to hear from the Dodgers about how
they got ripped off the Dodgers lost two
games in that World Series in their
ballpark they lost game two and Janssen
couldn't hold a 4-3 lead in the ninth
inning when Gonzalez at all run Astros
are not cheating on a road and then
dovish laid an egg and you know
basically you know peed all over himself
in Game seven if I can say that when
Springer had a couple of home runs and
that was in his home ball
the Yankees to me have a better case
because the Yankees won three games in
their Park in the ALCS in 2017 and then
lost four games in Houston so and
anybody's got a better case to scream in
yellows the Yankees you know and how
about Girardi yet your day lost his job
because of that series if they had won
that series and they had gotten to the
World Series Aaron Boone would not be
managing the Yankees today so that's the
story's got a lot of tentacles it's not
going away anytime soon and the Astros
are gonna have to figure out as a group
the players how they're gonna handle
this the first day of spring training
they can't ignore it forever
somebody's gonna have to be the team
leader and say you know what we were
wrong as a Gloop and so far that has not
been done they do that in a month all
right Chris you said a lot there let me
unpack it a little bit at a time first
things first I was at Craigs Wednesday
night I didn't see Bregman there
I did one number two why why are you
happy that they didn't name any other
players because a lot of the players
that you just said about the Astros may
not have actually done this my top you
know I made that I that provides peer
pressure that means if there is a guy
who's clean with Houston I got a fit and
not just clean had no idea this was
going on you know doesn't it as an aide
when you got to the plate but not
allowing but allowing this to go on when
you know it was wrong as the Astros even
the players who may have not used it
that's wrong too but I like the idea
that the actual players now get grouped
as a unit and it's not just two or three
guys they can yell and scream about
furthermore I know people have moaned
and groaned about that you know what
that issue would have been for the
commissioner's office if tony clark got
his hand on this clark would have
appealed this to no end this would have
taken forever they got Ryan Braun off a
few years ago if you never that story
because of that appeal process with the
drugs this would have taken forever to
get settled and Manfred did not want
this in the newspapers for seven months
with some orbiter who likes to see all
the notoriety he gets look how long is
Bryant arbitration don't be hearing as
taken with the orbiter
so the idea I think he wanted to stay
away from that he
they handle the positions of authority
he did that and then let the astral
players squirm so I understand other
people say let's name them let's put
them all in some trouble but in this way
in a lot of ways it makes it better
because now the whole group gets nailed
and so they're gonna be some infighting
order now guys why am I getting accused
of this I didn't do this
so that actually causes friction with
the franchise first I have no plan with
man for not telling anybody Christmas
I'm not the players were Kris Mad Dog
Russo here on the Rich Eisen show and
then you know you make a good point that
that some teams have a certain leg to
stand on when complaining about how it's
affected them and others don't the
Yankees did lose four games in that ALCS
all in in Houston but the first game
they only scored two and then the second
game if you remember that was when
Verlander was throwing seeds and they
couldn't they couldn't hardly I'm not
doing that just a quote-unquote catch
it's just my basic point is we just
don't know what was used when it was
used when it wasn't used or how to what
effect it was possibly used we just know
it was used in it stinks and that may be
one of the things to why the Mets went
and hired Beltran is because everybody
was doing it and that's that's the other
thing like what how rampant has this
been in Major League Baseball because it
sure seems like as we're watching the
games you and I as fans about ball
strikes and we're you know I'm sitting
here every day complaining about the
shift and how that's affecting baseball
what's really been affecting baseball is
the cheating like you know who knows how
many teams are or doing this you know on
a day-to-day basis I did have Terry
Francona on yesterday on the TV and I
asked him specifically that very
question he said Chris I can't answer
for anybody else but you on my soul we
do not do this nonsense and if I saw it
I would have stopped it I've been around
long enough to know that this is not the
right thing to do so take it for what
it's worth I mean you wouldn't think the
Yankees would be doing this because
they've been screaming yells yeah left
and right you wouldn't think the Dodgers
are doing this because they obviously
down deeper very annoyed
I had Dodger people tell me at the
Winter Meetings you know what's what's
my retribution what I gotta listen to is
1988 left and right what do I get for
this 2017 nonsense so you know you like
to think it's not rampant to sport your
guess is as good as mine but the most
important thing here is that Manfred
sent out a message guys you don't think
I'm serious with those two memorandums I
sent out in September of 17 and then the
following March and you embarrass me by
basically ignoring them and make me look
bad
I'll show you so now everybody's on
notice that if you get me out with this
you're gonna get destroyed so I agree
with you I can't pinpoint nobody can the
usage with all the teams for a long
period of time but I'd be shocked if
anybody does it now well they would why
would you go through that nonsense and
the Mets had a fire Bell trend I don't
know how they had a fire boh-chan Red
Sox he'll do the same with Cora Klain
had no choice - yeah I was gonna ask you
how the how the beltron stuff's playing
in New York how's it playing I think
most people I think that I think the
issue about saying they're rich is that
the fans are really getting on von wagon
and he doesn't have a lot of collateral
to begin with and I think the idea that
he interviewed Beltran for basically
eight nine straight hours
and didn't get to the bottom of the
astral thing you know late October early
November and then of course you know
eight days or 10 days later that
athletic story comes out I think how in
the world a Brody said he didn't ask the
questions
so people are you know they don't love
Brody anyway so the idea that Brody
I think Brody is taking the hits Beltran
is Beltran Met fans don't love Beltran
one way or the other that postseason
series when he struck out looking with
Wainwright still bothers some diehard
Mets fan
so the Met fan I think is okay with no
train going I think now they're worried
about Vaughn wagon and they don't love
the will ponds as you know right yeah
Chris mad dog you sir here and and and
again just to put this one item to bed
before I just quickly ask you about the
championship Sunday is that now all of
us as fans we're looking to see like
where the we're parsing home run trot
Slyke it's the Zapruder film all right
we're looking at Wow
right he's holding his jersey he's
holding his jersey because we all are
thinking like okay so the trash can
stuff's been out the window now they're
trying to actually wear a device where
they can get buzz to about the type of
pitch that's coming and for sure for
somebody's throwing 100 miles an hour
like Chapman for somebody to yank an
off-speed pitch like he knew it was
coming is the only other phrase to put
it and he's running around the bases
holding on her - please don't rip my
Jersey off I mean the whole thing does
kind of stink to high heaven Christopher
and I have not seen that video but I
know a lot of Yankee fans are very
annoyed by that now I was a lousy pitch
he could have made contact we did hit
the ball four and eighty feet I
understand and you know that bothers a
Yankee fan a Yankee fan already got
squeezed out two years ago and I make it
a bit I also hurt springer may have had
wires or something so again once you
cheat once you're never going to get the
benefit of the doubt again so the Astros
I got to see the video is it that start
with coming around third he's coming
around third and they're all ready to
just jump on him at home plate and he's
pointing at his jersey don't take it off
and he holds on to it as he gets into
the pig pile and again that the word was
is that he's shy he doesn't want to have
you know is his t-shirt shown I mean
it's just the whole thing and so I just
want to go to a game with my kids and
say okay it's one two the reason why the
batter stepping out is he needs to think
about what pitch think once this pitcher
might be doing and the reason why the
pitchers throwing this is because he
used to throw them that now I'm
wondering you know is he waiting for a
whistle is he waiting for a bang is he
waiting for a buzz is the pitcher
stepping off because he's can't figure
out whether there is a whistle or a bang
or a buzz and that's the sort of cat and
mouse crap that I'm not going to the
stadium for Chris a hundred percent and
that's one of the reasons why these
games takes very we'll all these mount
visits and everything else listen uh you
know I'm listening the baseball looks in
a funny way it's actually hope baseball
because I think we were waiting
a watershed moment for Manford you know
I think you know he'd been the
Commissioner for three years we haven't
had that watershed moment for him and I
think he did a good job
I - some people think it told Google are
enough with crane
should have named players as you
mentioned but I think you know he came
now putting on here I mean he did
suspend three-man
you know cores out forget - I mean he
definitely sent a message to the Mets
about beltran loon I was never gonna
work again Hinch gets a year he fined
him five million bucks he took away four
picks first and second rounders two
years in a row I mean I think he did a
pretty good job but I know there are
some people who didn't think he went
quite far enough I have no problem that
I think he did he also outlined his
discipline Wells 9 pages he was very
thorough whenever this is a guy that
went to Harvard Law School Cornell and
Harvard he's no dummy
he's a lawyer he crossed his T's doubt
of the eyes I think he came across low
so I think it actually helps him and as
far as the sport is concerned let's face
of it you're having me on today Friday
before the championship game like
breaking down the Astros now I know it's
negative news but it does get baseball
on the back burner for a little while on
the front burner for a little while
which is not bit all right so next week
on Mad Dog Unleashed you're gonna be
given away a chance to win a parrot
giving away a pair of tickets Super Bowl
50 for people answering your NFL trivia
questions I live I've always loved
hearing that for years so what do you
think happens Sunday Christopher I think
that'd be one close game and I think
there'd be one game that the home team
will play well in and you know dominate
so I will go Chiefs easy
27:10 something along those lines and I
think the Niners and Packers might be a
little closer than you think
I think the fact the Packers got killed
out there the first time will help them
I also think that honestly get a little
tight I don't know why I think that was
Kvapil oh but I do first championship
game that close to the you know getting
little Super Bowl Chiefs win this spot
last year at home losing the Pats
I think that helps them some so I
actually think that Kansas City is gonna
wear and e-readers do he's been down
this path a thousand times so I think
it's I think Kansas City will win easy
San Francisco Green Bay game will close
I gotta take San Francisco their home
and they're better they got a good
defense you know then banged up
receiving core you gotta take the Niners
but I think that game will be closer to
you and what do you think happens with
Brady that's the other big Scottie got
to support house in Greenwich 450
million Connecticut amazed you buy a
house in Greenwich is gonna play for the
Chargers III just don't take his kids
out of school I just do not see that I
think that Brady will probably stay with
the patch so right now that McDaniels
gonna have to stay with the Pats and his
buddies there of course in the offensive
coordinator I think at the end of the
day has stay with New England all right
Christopher thanks for the time I will
always look forward to seeing you at the
Super Bowl going forward you got that
seat right next to me let me watch I
love going on Mad Dog unleash and having
you hold me accountable for NFL
decisions I have nothing to do about
that look forward to that Thank You
Christopher yeah boy alright that's
Chris Mad Dog Russo Mad Dog sports radio
on Sirius XM right here in the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app